foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is scp-5462
containment class Euclid
disruption class vlam
and risk class notice
special containment procedures
scp-5462-a has been placed in site-21's
media archive Wing Foundation Assets in
art institutions and auction houses have
been placed on alert for a Goya painting
matching
scp-5462-bs effects
description
scp-5462-a is the Journal of Spanish
painter Francisco Goya detailing an
anomalous event that resulted in the
creation of 15 oil paintings painted
between 1819 and 1822 commonly referred
to as his black paintings due to their
emotionally disturbing contents themes
and use of dark colors
the paintings were painted onto the
walls of his Villa in his country estate
on the outskirts of Madrid nicknamed the
Quinta del sordo House of the deaf man
named after previous death inhabitant
and not after going a contrary to
popular belief while all 14 paintings at
The Prado Museum in Madrid have been
confirmed as non-anomalous the journal
describes a 15th unconfirmed painting
While most Scholars point to heads in a
landscape as the 15th black painting an
examination by Foundation archivists
reveals it was not painted in the same
period as the others designated
scp-5462b that has been described as
having significant anomalous properties
the status of
scp-5462-b is unknown
addendum 5462 1. truncated biography of
Francisco Goya Francisco Goya 30th of
March 1746 to 16th of April 1828 has
been considered as one of the most
popular Spanish painters of his time
born to a lower class family in Aragon
he was interested in art from an early
age Goya studied under Spanish Baroque
painter Jose lazan at the age of 14
copying stamps for four years he would
eventually grow tired of this moving to
Madrid to study under Anton Rafael menx
and then later to Rome which was
considered the cultural capital of the
world at the time
his career only seemed to grow at this
point receiving Awards Royal commissions
and an appointment to a position as a
member of the Royal Academy of Fine Art
goya's career appeared to reach New
Heights when he was commissioned to
paint the portrait of the count of
Florida Blanca in 1783 becoming
introduced to the Royal Court only three
years later Goya would become a painter
in service to King Charles III later
becoming the first court painter under
Charles IV
somewhere between 1792 and 1793 Goya
fell prey to an illness that left him
deaf he grew more withdrawn and insular
with his Works shifting to a darker tone
such as his capricious Prince which he
described as the innumerable foibles and
Follies to be found in any civilized
society and from the common prejudices
and deceitful practices which custom
ignorance or self-interest have made
usual Goya complained of loud noises
within his head as well as poor vision
and balance historians have speculated
on the cause of the illness with most
suspecting a case of Meniere's disease
or lead poisoning resulting from a
lifetime of creating his own paints the
invasion of Spain by France in 1808 and
the death of his wife in 1812 did little
to alleviate his mood once one of the
most famous painters of his time Goya
retreated to a life of solitude in the
Madrid Countryside possibly due in part
to fear of political reprisals where he
created his Infamous black paintings
in 2004 the foundation came into the
possession of goya's Journal detailing a
series of events that had occurred at
Quinta del sordo the journal had been
sold at a marshall Carter and dark
auction as the recollection of goya's
brush with the anomalous initially
appraised at 1 million euros several
bids from unidentified members of the
audience Drew attention leading the
embedded Foundation planned to purchase
the journal for 3 million euros
addendum 5462-2
scp-5462-a excerpt
I dreamed that I was young I was on the
road to Rome 60 years between then and
now faded away like a nightmare and all
that remained were sunny skies and Lofts
of Joy the road behind us and in front
of us stretched on forever into an
indistinct pathway of bliss
and then I woke up woke in this decrepit
aging form where my hearing has vanished
and my vision blurs into an indistinct
chaos Beyond barely a league if my
younger selves from scant 50 years ago
were to gaze upon me now he would label
me a corpse
even now I'm tired of writing and the
sun has barely sunk below the Horizon a
new day shall arise tomorrow
perhaps I will pick up my brushes again
I can find some small comfort in them at
least
I write this last entry in bed where I
have been sequestered for a cold after A
Series of Unfortunate Events
I attempted to paint again today Leo
Cadia thought it would restore my
spirits to do so helping me purchase
some canvas and supplies
and setting a well-cushioned chair in
the countryside
I had the image of the hills and the
Rising Sun clear in my mind and yet
every time I held my brush every time I
intended to change the ephemeral to a
lasting image it twisted out of my head
and vanished leaving me staring at a
blank canvas like a simpleton I
attempted to paint the Rising Sun and
the Noonday sun and the setting sun over
and over again until I was sitting in
darkness attempting to paint the Rising
Moon I wasn't even aware that the rain
had broke until leocadia came running in
a frenzy to hurry me inside
I may not be able to paint until I
return to full health but at least I can
make a few sketches to pass the time
hopefully this cold is over soon
term has called it's not the first time
I have fallen and prayed to it nor the
first time since my deafness but
something about this instance of the
malady is different just to stay awake
long enough to write these words feels
like a Titanic struggle
there is a particular queerness
surrounding my mind while I remain
sitting in my bed in the light of the
afternoon sun my mind feels far away
from the hands writing these words I
feel as if
the walls of this little bedroom have
crumbled to dust and I stand on a vast
plane I have not been transported to
some fanciful illusion a method of lochi
but I am only seeing what has always
been there the planes and the unnameable
things lurking in its Shadows that have
been present for all of Mankind's past
separated by only the thinnest of veils
today the veil was lifted from my soul
and I can see farther than any man ever
could
there are more things in Heaven and
Earth than are dreamed of in our
philosophy after all
but what are these places Beyond them
this is no ordinary illness I fear the
strangest thought the thoughts roaming
those murky planes of Beyond
that was their door
and I now see things that I should not
I had the strangest dream last night
where I was standing on a Cliffside I
looked up and saw light a foreign alien
light the type that cleansed Sodom and
Gomorrah and any impurity it's all fit
to remove I looked down and saw void an
Abyssal Darkness from out of the lowest
levels of this world plawing its way
higher and higher and consuming all it
past I felt paralyzed to move I knew I
was witnessing something Beyond My
Little World of art heart would reach me
first purifying light or all-consuming
Darkness both were a hand's breath away
from my refuge before iBook
I'm not sure what meaning I should take
away from it if any but I shall continue
to record my experiences
there is little else to do while I
remain Tethered to my bed
praying for this sickness to end swiftly
it seems praying has not worked in
ceasing this instead my thoughts have
been turned into a different direction
last night I Dreamed A City all of blood
with towers made of bone where Bloods
ran in the streets like water men and
women dance through the streets laughing
and kissing and praying and playing in
all while the blood splattered their
ignorant faces
there were no children in this city
there were never children
where were the children
I returned to the city again standing
below a Gateway I had no desire to see
those disgusting sights of those
cavorting among the blood and so I
turned away back to those strange and
Fantastical planes
I could see things impossible things
stalking me watching me offering an
outstretched hand while Whispering all
of the things that they could offer but
there was a stronger voice beckoning to
me from Beyond and those impossible
things fell by the wayside
I saw a shining city on a hill and I
knew that it was allegada
there are more things in allegada than I
dreamed of on Earth
there are more things in allegada than I
dreamed of on Earth
there are more things in our garden than
I dreamed of on Earth
there are more things in alagada than I
dreamed of on Earth there are more
things in alagada than are dreamed of on
Earth
after this last entry Goya ceased to
write complete entries for approximately
three weeks the 27 Pages following his
last entry were marked with illegible
writing alchemical symbols and quotes
from Christopher Marlow's the hanged
King's tragedy
[Music]
it is good to be on My Feet Again able
to walk outside in the fresh Castile air
after this lengthy illness a lesson I
learned sitting outside in the pouring
rain is not a mistake I will be making
again nor will leakeda allow me to
now that my mind is clearer that
Dreadful fog I've been able to turn it
towards painting
we may not have had much escudos left
for canvas but the walls served as a
possible substitute
Leo seems to have enjoyed watching me
paint the Pastoral murals
there is a certain Tranquility a certain
strength of spirit present in them that
portraits of kings and Nobles lack with
their distant and Regal gazes it's
rather nourishing to create
I should remember to write in this more
often it is rather odd that I left this
blank for three weeks
is this some sort of divine jest has God
not been satisfied with my wife and my
hearing and my work
I thought I would be able to hold on to
my sight or at least what precious
little remains of it but it seems he is
determined to steal it away too
I can see now that these putrid
disgusting little peasants are nothing
more than moldy globules of paint on a
wall That's quickly crumbling away how
could leakeda think to allow me to start
such a foolish project how can I allow
myself
I must start again this may be the last
work I ever achieve
nothing what has happened to me it is as
if there is a hole in my head and all my
ideas all the creativity that made me
director of the Royal Academy and the
court painted to Charles IV has simply
trickled down the side of my head and
dissipated into nothing I could not
paint a shadow to save my life today
perhaps this is it perhaps my life is
truly over that there is nothing left
for me to do but lay down and wait for
God to take me
my head is aching intensely
I need to rest
I saw them
every painting I've ever created every
childhood Mash of colors every saint and
King and Noble and Angel and fair lady
that ever sprang from my mind
they were as clear as day before me
they mocked me
scorned me
I I was Kronos the decrepit feeble
backwards Relic and they were the
Olympians deathless terrible and
beautiful they had sprung from me true
but they no longer had need of me and
resisted my pleadings
but even kronos's generation and his
parents the earth and the sky came from
somewhere else older darker places which
you dared not name for fear that they
would hear you and it rose up behind me
in all its terrible Glory I could not
turn to face it for I knew that it would
annihilate me like Zeus to somehow but I
could sense its presence and see the
gods turn from mockery to fear Now They
begged me to save them to take them back
and continue my great artwork
they were erased annihilated like the
stars torn from the heavens themselves
and up from the soil back up my head to
the hole in the side of it something
else came to fill in the void
I can no longer tell if I'm awake or
dreaming
it came today all these months its order
all this maddening solitary the sheer
decades I have spent watching my life
erode into nothingness it has come to
this
it has come to alagada
it slipped out of my head and onto my
own personal canvas a perfect ideal of
eligada made manifest it spoke to me of
all the sweetest words I have ever known
I feel as if I've been reunited with a
dear old friend who I have been missing
for all my life
the painting has given me new life and
in return I have created dozens more
leocadia has expressed some concerns
about the manic energy that has infused
me over these past few weeks but
I have paid her no mind she has not seen
the enlightenment
the painting has extended me an
invitation from the hand of the
Ambassador itself I am welcome to step
foot into elegata at any time but it
requires a particular service of me
first it has directed me to go to France
to the residents of an artist by the
name of Theodore jericholt I need no
other direction than my presence
as we are both fortunate enough to share
a patron in the wearer of the anguished
mask
a large number of pages have been torn
out the edges are encrusted over with
unidentifiable black substance
for long years
four years of planning
and tedious Gatherings and speeches and
plotting
the work is not yet completed of course
but Theodore has assured me that he will
ensure our little movement spreads to
all corners of the globe there is a
certain spark in him something that
burns bright and warm like I imagined it
did in me in my younger years
I have no doubt he will see it through
now through my last great painting I
shall return home to alagada
for ages I felt paralyzed trapped in an
aging body as my life slowly and but now
I can see that it has barely begun we
the living only think of Our Lives as
what we can experience what we touch
what we say a reaction we take before
our time in the ground arrives
but the lives of artists stretch beyond
that to every being and power and
countries shaped by our work
we live on through the minds of youths
and kings and Nobles for as long as our
name endures
and through this work I shall become
immortal
I ask only one question to those who
might find these words and reflect
upon the movement that Theodore and I
have birthed
are we magnificent yet
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Indy versus the world
except
tomothy
zargaron
the Morrigan
fire of prime
Spencer arduin
rubbish bin 69.
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J telp
vinyl
zazapan
Lemke
Dr Briggs
signor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
Lyndon B Johnson
oh crop guy
and James Saba
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos found some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you
thank you